[Música]
[Aplausos]
posiblemente te haya despedido de
alguien sin saberlo
hay en tu casa en alguna estantería un
libro que no vas a volver a abrir nunca
y hoy aquí en este evento muchos de
nosotros nos estamos viendo por última
vez
yo tendría unos 17 años cuando leí esto
que les estoy contando con otras
palabras en un poema de borges que se
titula límites ese poema me sacudió
yo no podía entender que alguien a quien
yo admiraba tanto hubiera escrito algo
tan trágico como que cada día sin darnos
cuenta nos estábamos despidiendo de algo
o de alguien
llega a obviar ese poema pero no me
podía quitar de la cabeza el tema de la
despedida
se han preguntado alguna vez qué pasa en
nuestro cerebro cuando sabemos que el
tiempo se ha terminado
parece que delante de la muerte cuando
ya no queda tiempo nuestra mente busca
de forma instintiva casi mecánica como
un salvavidas aquellos recuerdos que han
tenido para nosotros mayor carga
emocional y en los estudios que le
aparecía una idea interesante
muchos de esos recuerdos se habían
grabado durante la infancia en ese
tiempo en el que fuimos niños sin otro
objetivo que exprimir el presente
recordé entonces que lo había visto
muchas veces en la vida real y en la
literatura en la música y en el cine
pensé por ejemplo en los últimos días de
antonio machado agotado y enfermo
habiendo cruzado ya la frontera con
francia la muerte fue a buscarlo y él le
había dejado en el bolsillo de su abrigo
el último verso que había escrito
estos días azules y este sol de la
infancia
infancia pueden imaginar un color y una
luz más intensos para saludar a la
muerte que el recuerdo de un niño
cuando leí 100 años de soledad tuve que
repetir el comienzo varias veces porque
en ese principio extraordinario estaba
el mismo verso que escribiera machado
con otras frases pero esos días azules y
este sol de la infancia estaban ahí
muchos años después frente al pelotón de
fusilamiento el coronel aureliano
buendía había de recordar aquella tarde
remota en que su padre lo llevó a
conocer el hielo como machado aquel
coronel a punto de ser fusilado
intentaba iluminar una vida se apagaba
con el recuerdo vivo del niño que fue y
he vuelto encontrarme con ese recuerdo
muchas veces pero yo no dejaba de
preguntarme por qué necesitamos ese
salto a la infancia es que dejamos de
vivir que una intensidad cuando ya no
somos niños
en la canción de las simples cosas se
dice que uno vuelve siempre a los viejos
sitios donde amó la vida entonces
dejamos de amar la vida cuando crecemos
hay un campo la psicología que se
denomina psicología del tiempo y que
estudia por ejemplo cómo se graban
nuestros recuerdos
se dice que de niños es más fácil grabar
intensamente algunos momentos porque
apenas tenemos pasado y a menudo estamos
haciendo cosas por primera vez pero eso
no lo explica todo por eso quería
dejarles una comparación imaginen que
nuestro tiempo es como un lienzo como un
paisaje que se va coloreando poco a poco
con nuestras emociones si dejamos de
hacer cosas que nos hagan sentir vivos
que nos emocione ese paisaje se va
apagando
se incluye en el problema verdad
pues si el problema es que dejamos muy
pronto de pintar ese paisaje y empezamos
a garabatear lo de manera automática
estamos sufriendo una epidemia terrible
que tiene una enorme influencia en el
estrés la ansiedad o la depresión y esa
epidemia invisible no es otra que la
vida en modo automático
la vida en modo automático es necesaria
tenemos la memoria de hábitos que es la
que nos activa el piloto automático que
necesitamos muy a menudo para vivir pero
se puede convertir en nuestra enemiga y
se domina nuestro tiempo esa memoria de
hábitos hace que las emociones
desaparezcan y que los días tengan
siempre un mismo color
si quieren saber hasta qué punto estamos
contagiados hay un termómetro que nunca
falla
el lenguaje porque nosotros nos
comunicamos sentimos y pensamos a través
de las palabras y ellas nos delatan a
menudo decimos por ejemplo que
necesitamos desconectar recargar pilas
recargar pilas es como si aceptáramos
que realmente somos máquinas que vivimos
conectándonos y desconectando nos como
autómatas hablamos como si el único fin
que tuvieran nuestro tiempo fuera el de
volver con más energía a las
obligaciones
parece algo sin importancia pero
repetido mil veces cada día ese lenguaje
va calando en nosotros y en los más
pequeños
suelo hacer con mis estudiantes una
prueba el primer día de curso yo lo
llamo el horario emocional les entrego
el horario lectivo con las asignaturas y
les pido que me rellene con un emoticono
de tristeza o de alegría otro horario en
blanco
empiezan a llenar de caras tristes los
lunes los martes los miércoles los
jueves los viernes me ponen las primeras
sonrisas
pero llega el domingo supuestamente
libre saben qué hace
me ponen caras tristes por la tarde
claro el domingo se ha manchado con el
color del lunes ellos ya anticipan de
qué color va a ser cada día no lo eligen
los lunes son oscuros siempre
lo peor es que a menudo esa percepción
son las huellas que los mayores dejamos
en sus paisajes vivimos saltando de fin
de semana en fin de semana de vacaciones
en vacaciones
saben lo duro que espera chicos de 11 o
12 años cada curso aceptando que de
lunes a jueves
lo normal es estar triste apagado
y nosotros nos preguntamos qué está
fallando los que estamos fallando somos
nosotros los adultos y estamos fallando
en lo más importante
hay algo peor que hacerles creer que se
puede vivir así sin emociones esperando
siempre al próximo fin de semana
tal vez por eso me molestan tanto
algunas palabras nuevas ahora se ha
puesto de moda en llamar viernes al
jueves
porque así parece que el viernes estamos
cerca es decir en lugar de intentar
darle al jueves un color vivo lo
borramos directamente yo creo que hay
que empezar a llamar a las cosas por su
nombre
vivir en modo automático no es vivir
dejar de bailar de jugar de pintar por
falta de tiempo no es madurar ni es
responsable es una forma lenta de
suicidio
ahora nos bombardean con la idea de que
el éxito o el fracaso dependen de
nuestro desarrollo profesional o del
número de seguidores en las redes yo
siempre he pensado que el éxito o el
fracaso dependen de nuestra relación con
el tiempo el mayor fracaso en mi opinión
es levantarse cada lunes pensando en el
viernes
y entonces qué podemos hacer
como salimos del modo automático bueno
no vamos a engañarnos no es fácil en una
sociedad que te empuja a vivir así
siempre entretenidos o trabajando por
inercia
por eso creo que es fundamental que
tomemos conciencia de la despedida
aceptar la despedida de alguna forma es
aceptar que la muerte nos borra un
pedacito de ese paisaje cada día pero al
mismo tiempo eso significa que nos queda
una parte por pintarlo
volviendo a ese poema de borges del
comienzo sí me pareció durísimo cuando
lo leí de joven ese poema ha ido
creciendo conmigo
y ahora se ha convertido en un mantra
que me repito cada vez que siento que
entrado en modo automático
preguntarnos recordarnos que estaremos
haciendo hoy por última vez
hay quien estaremos viendo hoy por
última vez es una alarma que puede
despertarnos que nos pueda ayudar a
relativizar lo negativo ya vivir con más
intensidad
quiero confesarles algo
yo me crié en un paté de vecinos y en
ese patio grabé algunos de mis momentos
más intensos
allí también vivía farina un vecino al
que llamaban así porque cantaba muy bien
flamenco
yo no sabía lo que era el flamenco pero
con los demás chicos del patio yo
escuchaba farina hipnotizados porque
cuando necesitaba desahogarse él cantaba
mirando una pared blanca en la que él
veía a su madre
en esta pared no había nada ni nadie
pero farina veía a su madre y le cantaba
a ella a veces llorando
los mayores nos decían que nos
metiéramos en casa y lo dejáramos
tranquilo pero yo no podía moverme yo me
quedaba hipnotizado y lo miraba con ese
asombro de quién sabe que está viviendo
algo único
así yo crecí pensando que el mundo era
más grande de lo que me contaban mis
sentidos y mucho más grande de lo que me
contaban los mayores porque había
puentes como el flamenco que permitían
que los que estaban vivos y los que ya
se habían ido siguieran conversando
han pasado los años muchos y sabe
sigo creyendo en esos puentes en esas
máquinas del tiempo como el flamenco la
literatura o un evento como ese que
permiten que personas que murieron antes
de que yo naciera sigan conversando
conmigo y cambien mi presente
antes la gente se preguntaba si un libro
podía cambiar el mundo
ahora que casi nadie lee la gente se
pregunta directamente si un libro sirve
para algo
por lo que estoy contando imaginen que
yo soy de esas personas a las que unos
cuantos libros le cambiaron la mirada su
mundo por eso aunque no están de moda ni
hagan tanto ruido yo he querido traer
conmigo dos de esas máquinas del tiempo
que cambiaron para siempre mi relación
poner el primer libro que leí y el
primero que leí en otro idioma
el primer libro que leí fue como mi
padre que andaba por aquí
sabía que me encantaba leer tebeos y
cuentos así que un día dejó sobre mi
almohada este libro de michael ende
yo lo abrí y aunque apenas tenía dibujos
comencé a leerlo me engancho desde la
primera página este libro ya me hablaba
de la sociedad del vértigo en la que
vivimos una sociedad repleta de hombres
grises que te empujan a vivir corriendo
a ser más productivo para que nunca te
pares a pensar que estás haciendo con tu
vida
los hombres grises te prometen que si
ahora no te detienes algún día podrás
invertir todo ese tiempo ahorrado en lo
que más está llena pasear viajar
escuchar música
pero ese día nunca llega le suena
familiar verdad
ese día nunca llega porque lo más
valioso que tiene el tiempo es que no se
puede ahorrar sólo vivir saber lo más
increíble
he tenido etapas en mi vida en que si no
hubiera sido por este libro no me habría
dado cuenta de que yo mismo me estaba
convirtiendo en uno de esos hombres
grises que yo mismo estaba pensando que
invertir bien el tiempo era estar
siempre ocupado llenar el día de
actividades aunque no sintiera ninguna
no tengo dudas de que si hoy tuviera que
dejar un libro sobre la almohada de un
niño ese sería mi
nos hacen falta muchas mamás paseando
tranquilamente por las calles y los
parques
desafiando con su mirada a esa plaga de
hombres grises que no deja de crecer
el otro libro que estuvo para siempre mi
conciencia del tiempo fue el primero que
leí en francés el principito
lo hizo con un fragmento que no envejece
el principito bien está hablado amistad
con una rosa bastante altiva que siempre
repetía que era única en el mundo el
principito le tenía cariño pero un día
después de un largo viaje tropezó con un
jardín repleto de rosas todas idénticas
no se lo podía creer llorando se fue
hablar con su amigo el zorro para
contarle que se sentía engañado
traicionado esa rosa que le había dicho
que era única en el mundo era el final
idéntica a todas esas rosas del jardín
entonces el zorro le da una lección que
nunca olvidaría
diciéndole es el tiempo que has perdido
por tu rosa lo que la hace tan
importante con esa frase el le
quita la responsabilidad a la rosa y se
la pone directamente al principito
porque somos nosotros los que tenemos la
responsabilidad de elegir qué rosas
queremos que sean importante en nuestra
vida porque al invertir nuestro tiempo
ese que nunca vamos a recuperar somos
nosotros los que las hacemos importantes
en esta época de redes sociales y
pantallas inteligentes ese fragmento nos
regala un mensaje todavía más potente
porque cuando el principito pierde su
tiempo por su rosa no se conforma con
estar a su lado le dedica lo más
importante su atención
hoy más que nunca es posible estar al
lado de una persona sin estar con ella
lo vemos cada día verdad unos padres
hablando con su hijo que con los
auriculares puestos no levanta la mirada
de la pantalla una pareja en un
restaurante cada uno con su móvil a
menos de un metro pero kilómetros de
distancia
por eso yo creo que cada vez hay más
gente
se puede sustituir fácilmente a una
persona por otra les prestan tan poco
atención que todas les parecen iguales
no hablan desde dentro no escuchan no
miran hace tiempo que dejaron de pintar
por todo lo que le he contado ya
imaginan que no estoy de acuerdo con el
refrán que dice más vale tarde que nunca
si se trata de algo importante en sus
vidas de una conversación pendiente de
un cambio necesario
del poco tiempo atención que dedican a
su rosa o de evitar el contagio de los
hombres grises más vale ahora que nunca
no sabemos de qué o de quién nos estamos
despidiendo en este día
apaguemos el modo automático y elijamos
un color para pintarlo
es cierto que no somos eternos pero
todavía hoy sin necesidad de volver a la
infancia podemos seguir creando momentos
que si lo sean gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]